آه كيت ميدلتون كاثرين أميرة
ويلز في المستشفى بعد
خضوعها لعملية جراحية في البطن، لدى CNN Mac
Foster المزيد حول هذا الأمر حيث
بدأنا للتو في الحصول على مزيد من التفاصيل
وماكس، ما الذي تسمعه وكيف
حالها بشكل جيد إنها في المستشفى في البطن
الجراحة كما تقول، من المتوقع أن
تبقى في المستشفى لمدة تصل إلى أسبوعين
وسيتعين عليها التعافي أو
التعافي لمدة تتراوح بين شهرين إلى ثلاثة أشهر، لذا
من المتوقع أن يكون لها
تأثير كبير عليها، لقد تحدثت للتو مع كيت
مصدر أخبرني أنه يريد التأكيد
على أنه
غير سرطاني ومن الواضح أن هناك
قدرًا كبيرًا من الاهتمام بهذا الأمر وهم
يحاولون إدارة أنهم
لن يقدموا لنا أي تحديثات كبيرة
ما لم يكن هناك شيء ما  مهم أه
أن أعلن أنهم يريدون من الجميع
احترام خصوصيتهم ولكن يمكنني أن أخبرك
أنك تعلم أن وسائل الإعلام
تتجمع بالفعل خارج المستشفى آه على
الطريق هنا في لندن وهناك
قدر كبير من الاهتمام بالطبع في
الأوقات الوحيدة التي يمكنني فيها ذلك  أعتقد حقًا أنها كانت
في المستشفى من قبل، وقد تم إخبارنا
بذلك عندما أنجبت أطفالها الثلاثة،
وكانت شخصًا يتمتع بلياقة بدنية وصحية للغاية،
وحريصة جدًا على ممارسة الرياضة، لذا كانت
مفاجأة بعض الشيء، ولكن عندما رأيتها  لقد
بدت في حالة جيدة مؤخرًا خلال عيد الميلاد، لذا سيتعين علينا
الانتظار لنرى ما هي التحديثات الأخرى التي سنحصل عليها،
نعم، وأعني كما
نعلم جميعًا أن أي شيء يتعلق
بجراحة البطن يمكن أن يكون خطيرًا حقًا
ويمكن أن يكون أي شيء  نحن نعلم
أن هذا مؤلم حقًا ولا أحد يستطيع ولن
نقفز إلى أي استنتاجات حول ما
يمكن أن يكون ولكنهم أكدوا على ما إذا كان
صحيحًا أن هذه كانت
عملية جراحية مخطط لها في البطن أم نعم بالفعل لذا علينا
التحدث إلى شركائنا  الخبراء الطبيون لما
قد يكون ذلك على أساس أنه
غير سرطاني أيضًا، وأنت تعلم كما تعلم
حسنًا، أنت تعرف أن
جراحة البطن كما اقترحت، هل
تعلم أنها يجب أن تمر عبر تلك الطبقات
والعضلات وتستغرق الأمر  وقت طويل
للتعافي، لذلك آه إنهم ينظرون إليك كما تعلم من
شهرين إلى ثلاثة أشهر من التعافي
وقد ألغوا بالفعل جميع آه
السفر المستقبلي في الوقت الحالي حتى يعرفون
كلًا من أم كيت الأميرة ولكن أيضًا
أه الأمير ويليام أيضًا أم لكنها
سيتمكنون من العودة إلى وندسور، لقد
قيل لي أن أذهب إلى منزلهم في وندسور أه
لإجراء فترة الاستجمام هذه لأنها
تعلم أن هذه هي قاعدتهم الرئيسية
بينما يكون الأطفال في المدرسة
القريبة